we're now going to take another look
at lev shestov's classic early work all
things are possible
in an earlier video i talked about some
of the
key themes i gave a sort of introduction
to what shustop was doing in this this
aphoristic work which is a number of
different very short
essays and passages strung together some
of them only a few lines some of them
several pages long
and this time i want to focus on
what we can call his critique of
philosophy
not a philosophy as such
in every case across the board but a
critique of philosophy
as it's found in modern western
and also of the russia of his time
culture
why do i want to focus on this because
this is a set of
threads that run through the entire work
there are many other
important themes so any sort of
assemblage of them is going to be sort
of an arbitrary kind of set of cuts
across
chestnut's work but i think it's it's
worth keeping in mind
he is a critic of several philosophers
in particular
kant especially um but also
some of the thinkers that we would think
of as
utilitarianism in a very broad sense
positivism
really anybody who's doing metaphysics
in its traditional sense particularly in
its post-conscience sense
and he's he's focusing on on
examining what these people are doing
and contrasting them against individuals
like say
dostoyevsky or nietzsche people that
will come to
call existential slater and also people
like
shakespeare he's contrasting them
because there's something that gets lost
in in the process so i want to focus on
two longer passages in the second part
of the work
to sort of get us started and and you'll
see why i'm picking these up
he's diagnosing the problem problematic
situation of his time
which i think is still the problematic
situation of our own time
so here's how the passage is run and
i'll introduce commentary from time to
time he says
the ancients were right not in vain as
our earth called a veil of tears
and sorrow and once questions are
started it's impossible and unseemly to
hurry the answers
still as to anticipate the questions
the situation is so palpably absurd that
only with the intention of getting rid
of the question at any cost will one
strive for a sensible answer
the answer must be absurd
if you don't want it don't question
there's much more to be said about that
but i want to pause for a moment
so we're struck by the absurdity of
things
and we we question the universe
ourselves
god other people society
pick whatever you you like as the
interlocutor for our questions
we question we we say this doesn't make
sense
and if the question itself is in certain
respects
absurd in response to absurdity we
shouldn't be surprised if the answers
quite
often turn out to be in the broad sense
also absurd chest off things we're not
looking for although this is the trap
that that we always fall into
we're not looking for questions that
will be val or answers that would be
valid for every
being at every time you know in sort of
a conscience sense
all rational beings as such
what we're looking for are answers that
can satisfy us
and that doesn't mean that we just pick
whatever we like
you know we choose whatever is going to
satisfy our our interests
or our sort of superficial demands
but we can't approach questions and the
process of answering them
with the preconception that when we find
an answer it will apply to everybody
equally
so he goes on he says but if you must
question
then be ready beforehand to reconcile
yourself with something like
solipsism or modern realism thought is
at a dilemma
and dare not take the leap to get out we
laugh at philosophy and as long as
possible avoid evil
but nearly all men feel the intolerable
cramp of such a situation
and each at his risk ventures to swim to
shore on some more or less witty theory
we we pick different
ways of understanding things all of us
have a philosophy
that we pick we endorse we we try to
live out whether we call it a philosophy
or not
and we do so because we need something
to answer these questions about what
what the hell am i doing here what is
life about what is the good what is the
bad
how should i behave how can i judge you
know whether i'm actually living well
uh what should my neighbor over there be
doing and what should i be doing with
him
and you know we these just spiral out
out of control these these questions
and so we we need some sort of
systematic way to to
make sense out of them and we do find
these and he says a few courageous ones
speak the truth but they're neither
understood nor respected
when a man's words show the depth of the
pain through which he has passed he is
not indeed condemned but the world
begins to talk of his tragic state of
soul
and to take out a mournful look fitting
to the occasion
and they misunderstand
what what things are about what the
thinker is trying to do
if we skip down a little bit he says for
thousands of years
man has sought to solve the great
mystery of life through a god conception
now remember shastaff is a religious
thinker but he's rejecting the kind of
god conception that we're seeing here
in many respects it's very augustinian
this notion that
our notion of god quite often is
a projection of our own wishes desires
imaginations and that's not adequate to
the actual
god that's out there as a matter of fact
it becomes an idol
that we we end up chaining ourselves to
rather than
having a connection to the real god so
he says
a god conception with theodicy and
metaphysical theories as a result both
of which deny the possibility of
a mystery this is a key idea
for shestop life is mysterious
life is shot through
with things that not only don't we know
but we don't even know
what we don't know in them and as we
probe into them
we discover there's there's depths below
depth below
depths and we can probe into them but we
can't completely illuminate them
there are things that do remain and have
to remain mysterious
so there are mysteries the odyssey and
metaphysics in their classical sense
try to explain away the mysteries
including the mystery of
of evil that's what theodicy is about
so he says
theodicy has long ago wearied us the
mechanistic theories
which contend that there is nothing
special in life that its appearance and
disappearance depend on the same laws as
those of the conservation of energy and
the indestructibility of matter
these look more plausible at first sight
but people don't take to them
interestingly we're going through the
same thing in our own time with you know
people making wild claims that go far
beyond the realms of
actual science saying yes we can fully
understand everything
everything through the mechanisms
through the theories
through the the what it makes available
of science
and technology whether it be our moral
life whether it be
whether god could possibly exist or not
whether it be
does free will exist and and you notice
that
no matter how many times it's reported
to us that well science has solved these
problems
and there's a new book out here who says
the author of whom says
i've actually proven that god can't
exist or god must exist or there's
something in our genes or there's
nothing in our genes
people treat it as as if
this is just plausible
an entertaining story that maybe they'll
pick up or maybe they won't
they were doing that in chestos time as
well like he says
no theory can survive man's reluctance
to believe in it in a word
good is not justified the expectations
placed on it reason has done no better
so overwatch mankind turned from its old
idols and then thrown madness and evil
we we find a shift and this is taking
place you know around the turn of the
century in the last century
uh towards decadence towards
looking at the dark side of human beings
and then you know
terrible things showed up on the scene
in a way that
nobody in europe could could ignore
through you know the first world war and
then you know the rise of
totalitarianism
of both left and right and
the second world war genocide all those
sorts of things made it made it
impossible
for a while to look away from from that
um but yes so we we
turn away from our old idols and thrown
madness and evil
and then he says um
who knows what our children are going to
do it may be that our children will take
fright at the task we've undertaken
and call us squandering parents and will
set themselves again to keeping up
treasures spiritual and material again
they will believe in ideals
progress and such like for my own part i
hardly have any doubt of it
shestop thinks that after every sort of
crash a spiritual crash
and explorations of you know what is
going on
um a new generation will arise that has
to
to create again out of whatever has been
ruined
make sense of it and then these old
ideals you know like
science logic morality are going to come
back on the scene
and he says solipsism and the cult of
groundlessness are not lasting and most
of all they're not to be handed down
the final triumph in life as with old
comedies
rest with goodness and common sense
history is known
many epochs like ours this is something
really interesting that he's saying
many people want to think that modernity
is something
totally special that there's a spiritual
crisis that takes place in modernity
that's
unlike any others incomparable to them
and therefore we must speak of say the
postmodern or
you know nihilism is showing up on the
scene
fully in modernity
chestnut doesn't think so chest off
thinks that that's always right around
the corner
and that certain epochs have been
characterized by this and there he's
you know really in agreement with
somebody like nietzsche i mean when
nietzsche is criticizing the
socratic and the alexandrine and his
his birth of tragedy
he's talking about something like
very akin to modern nihilism
we can see this happening not only you
know
in certain epochs in history but in
certain locations
a culture loses its its force its
conception
and begins to collapse in upon itself
why
not because of economic problems alone
but because of a loss of meaning this is
what he's talking about here
there's another passage another long
passage that sort of sets the scene as
well
this is section 16 out of the second
part he says man comes to the past we're
all experience seems exhausted
wherever he go wherever whatever he see
all is old and wearyingly familiar
this is this is an experience that we we
do encounter
once we reach a certain stage younger
people
often act as if this is the case but
they don't really know that that's the
case yet
he says most people explain this by
saying they really know everything and
from what they've experienced they can
infer all
experience this phase of the exhaustion
exhaustion of life usually comes to a
man between 35 and 40.
not seeing anything new the individual
assumes he's completely matured and has
the right to judge of
everything now this is exactly what
chest off is criticizing in a nutshell
this notion that well
from this portion that i've seen i have
exhausted all the possibilities and i
can extrapolate
to everything else and say it's all
going to be more or less like this i
have
i have figured out what the essential
shapes
of reality both inward and
outward can possibly be and now i can
actually go on to make sense of it all
but you notice when it's made sense of
it's it's it doesn't really matter very
much
so he says the fact of spiritual
stagnation should not be made the ground
for judging all life's possibilities
from known possibilities on the contrary
this should spur us to something new
such that stagnation should prove that
however rich and multifurious the past
may have been
it has not exhausted a tittle of the
whole possibilities
from what has been it is impossible to
infer
what will be it is equally impossible
this is what chest off
really wants to stress to us to infer
what cannot be it is impossible to have
something like a transcendental critique
of all possibilities and say
this is ruled out this is ruled in
why because we human beings are not that
sort of creature again he talks about
the
the culture of his time we are bored
stiff with regularity and sequence
confess it you also you men of science
at the mere thought of that however we
may think we can get no further than the
acknowledgement of the old regularity
and invincible disgust to any kind of
mental work overcomes us
to discover another law still another
when already we have far
more than we can do with surely if there
is any will to think left in us it is
established in the supposition
that the mind cannot and must not have
any bounds
chest off is about liberation just off
is about
freedom for the human being
because what has bound the human being
is only
other human beings and the human being
him or herself
placing themselves within the grip of
some sort of
assumed mechanism
some sort of imagined carapace you might
say
or armature in which they they believe
that they
must remain nothing actually binds us
within there
by necessity necessity itself is an
illusion according to
to shasta so he says
the theory of knowledge which is based
on the history of knowledge
and on very few doubtful assumptions is
only a piece of property belonging to a
certain
caste has nothing to do with us others
what a mad impatience seizes us at times
when we realized
that we shall never fathom the great
mystery every individual in the world
must have felt that one time the man
desired to unriddle the universe
even the stodgy philosophers who
invented the theory of knowledge like
kant
have at times made surreptitious sorties
hoping to open a path to the unknown
in spite of their own fat senseless
books that demonstrate the advantages
of scientific knowledge
man either lives in continuous
experience
or he frees himself from conclusions
imposed by limited experience
again we see the same theme coming up
over and over again
chest off is posing us with a dilemma
necessity versus freedom he talks about
at one point in here he's got this
brilliant phrase he calls morality
science and logic and any philosophy
that
is is operating according to to those
those police agents and think about what
policing does
policing enforces a kind of
order and why does it actually
work because of the will of the police
because of the will of those directing
them because of the wills
of those who allow themselves to be
coerced
who see the police coming and say
i better knock off what i'm doing
because you know
it's not going to cord with with these
things and i don't want them to
lock me up to give me a citation to
even verbally warn me to call my
attention
call me to my neighbor's attention
as being subversive as being deviant as
is not fitting in policing
is really and here chest off is you know
sort of
working off of nietzsche and going all
the way to anticipating somebody like
foucault or toulouse
it's a brilliant thinker um is is
realizing that a lot of what we call
culture including intellectual culture
including philosophy
is really a kind of policing
and he wants to try to break out of that
to break free of that
another set of passages now we're going
to the the
first part one of the passages that's
particularly relevant to understanding
why chest off is criticizing
certain ways of doing philosophy certain
certain
congealed or sedimented
pressures placed upon us when we start
to think in modern culture
we can find for example in this passage
number 118 in the first part he says
um he's criticizing the the sort of you
know german
idealistic post conscience philosophy he
says
the a priori of contemporary thought
convinces
more and more that nietzsche's instinct
was not all
not at all at fault the root of all our
philosophies lies not in our objective
observations but in the demands of our
own
heart in the subjective moral will
and he then says science cannot be
uprooted unless we we destroy morality
in part because
morality consists in an imposition of
upon ourselves of our own will and we'll
come back to that in a moment but i want
to now
move to another passage where he's
talking about something similar passage
101 in the first part he says every
philosophic world conception starts from
some or other solution of the general
problem of human existence and proceeds
from this to direct the course of human
life
in some particular direction or another
every time that we're doing
philosophy we are we are oriented
ultimately whether we admit this to
ourselves or not
in an existential way we're doing the
kind of philosophy that we're doing even
if it's the stupidest
most stultifyingly boring stuff in the
world and there's a lot of boring
philosophy out there trust me
um i'd study some of that as an
undergraduate and in graduate school
when we're doing that when we're
preoccupying ourselves with that when
we're thinking about that we are
choosing for ourselves
not only what sort of vocabulary
concepts terminology
mechanisms we're going to use to
understand things but what we're
actually going to pay attention to
what matters for us and then as we
we build it as we apply it as we even if
we're just complete doctrinaire
lockstep you know schematizers
we are still engaged in applying it
and that's our our will at work
what's going on there he says here's the
fundamental problem
we have neither the power nor the data
for the solution of general problems and
consequently all our moral deductions
are arbitrary
they only witness to one of two things
he says
moral that are the not moral uh
deductions prejudices if we are
naturally timid
or our propensities and tastes if we're
self-confident
what does he mean there well
prejudices we often think of prejudice
as meaning something that an individual
person has and it's their own sort of
stubbornness that they're stuck in
but no you know what a prejudice really
is is something inherited
from somebody else that we've taken on
and said yes that must be true i have to
i have to live according to it you know
if we're talking about racial prejudice
for example
a child doesn't become racist on their
own
they become racist by hearing other
people say well you know that group of
people there
don't don't associate with them they're
dirty and and you know
unclean and uh they you know they're
predatory
or lazy or pick whatever you like
and then if they're timid they don't
kick against that
and they don't uh they just sort of
accept it
they don't they don't refute it within
their themselves or their experience
and then it becomes a lens which they
use well the same thing happens with
philosophy
somebody goes to a you know philosophy
department and it's all analytic
philosophers or somebody goes and it's
all continental philosophers
or you know back in chestnut's day you
could have gone and it would have been
analytic or continental because they
weren't really on the scene at that time
it might have been that you know the
hegel's got it all right or kant's got
it all right or we're all empiricists
here
or we're all positivists not even not
logical positivists
later on but the comptian sort of or
spencerian kind of positivists
but why would you take that on why would
you assume that they actually have it
right well some people are naturally
timid they are more follower types
on the other hand our propensities and
tastes if we're self-confident
but is this a basis for actually
philosophizing
not just for oneself but for for
everybody
so to keep a prejudice is a miserable
unworthy business
so let's let's not you know expect that
um and you know any other sort of
way of understanding it it's going to be
based in our subjective
choices our wills let's not pretend like
that
actually applies to everybody either
does that mean that we have to actually
give up on philosophy though
you know traditionally think about
somebody like kant for example
if it's not valid for all rational
beings it's and this is just
paraphrasing this is not what he said
it's all crap it's worthless
well that that's kant's view of
philosophy that's not everybody's view
of philosophy
and and why the hell would we think that
we have to follow kant's view of
philosophy
do we just hear the words and they're
automatically convincing us
that the history of philosophy of
metaphysics up until now has just been a
history of error
well how does he know that does he
actually plumb the depths of
plato aristotle platinus you know
then going through you know augustine
and some aquinas
if you read kant he actually seems to
know something about these people but
aren't you kind of a sucker if you just
accept his word for it
the same thing could be said about in
our own time analytic philosophy or
continental philosophy of all the
different stripes
why automatically assume that nietzsche
got things right
why assume that you know philosophy is
fundamentally about argument
and that reading the history of
philosophy doesn't doesn't really
prepare one for for anything important
why assume that you have to put on the
hermeneutics of suspicion
why i assume that phenomenology is the
way to go
one takes these on and that is because
one chooses to
and then disguises from oneself the fact
that one is doing that and you could say
well
hey chest off why should i listen to
your stuff then
and chef stuff would say perfectly right
but i'm not claiming that what i'm doing
counts for everybody
or has to be taken as
the one philosophy as a matter of fact
what i'm advocating is something quite
different i'm advocating he says
let's try to you know come to an
understanding and
allow there to be different philosophies
out there
um let's permit this to to
to be the the case he uh he has a few
other things that are worth looking at
as well
uh with respect to this um
says the possibilities which open up
before mankind are sufficiently limited
in our lives it's impossible to see
everything
impossible to know everything impossible
to rise too high above the earth
impossible to penetrate too deeply down
what has been is hidden away
what will be we cannot anticipate and we
know for certain we shall never grow
wings
regularity immutably regular succession
of phenomena puts a term to our efforts
drives us into a narrow regular hard
beaten road of everyday life
but even on this road we may wander from
side to side
we can deviate from it
he says another life is conceivable
life in which the word disaster does not
exist where responsibility for one's
actions
at least has not such a deadly and
accidental weight and uh where on the
other hand there is no regularity but
rather an infinite number of
possibilities
that is what chest off is trying to to
get at
and these are the sorts of things that
shustop
thinks we have to take as our guides for
for philosophy not just books not just
consistency we have to actually pay
attention to our experience and we have
to treat our experience with the weight
that it deserves we
you know if we're going to say well i
need to go to experience don't pretend
like your experience is the definitive
experience
but do look at your experience rely upon
the imagination
don't take for granted kant or nietzsche
or heidegger or aj air or
pick whoever you like you know russell
or kripke or anybody telling you
that this is what can be thought this is
what's meaningful and everything outside
of that
is is nonsense or worthless or can't be
relied upon
don't even accept people who are
skeptics like him
saying no you can't you can't believe
this perhaps humans actually
wrong about some things experiment
put things to the test try them out
you know i i said in a previous video
that chest off is a radical empiricist
and and that's sort of along the same
lines as william james
james considered his form of pragmatism
to be a kind of
empiricism that required that you
actually
make a leap try things out and then
you'll find out what's on the other side
if you just try to make deductions about
it you know beforehand
well of course you'll never discover
anything interesting because you didn't
actually try anything
if you want to see whether there's
anything to religion go to church
not just once that's not an experiment
actually try something out
if you want to see whether the stoics
were onto anything about this you know
self-denial
leading to greater freedom try it out
do it do epictetus experiment to take a
sip of water and spit it out when you're
really thirsty
and then see what that happens see what
happens because of that
and do it maybe 30 times 30 days in a
row
if you want to see whether kant could
actually give you guidelines that could
make sense out of your life
read the con try to apply it we also
have to take uh
you know a guidepost from from our
suffering and the suffering of others we
have to pay attention to what goes on
we have to explore things we have to he
says that metaphysics
ought to be driven by passion not just
by by intellect alone
so shust off is going to be criticizing
a number of different developments
within contemporary
philosophy of his own time which are
really quite strong in our our own time
if we change the wording around a little
bit and make sense of it
he's going to say that there is a strong
thread current however you want to put
it
of utilitarianism running throughout the
the history of thought and particularly
in modern life
not because modern people are
necessarily different but because we we
communicate with each other more
and we when we call things into question
our justification for them quite often
in the end is well this is what works
you know and by what works we don't just
mean pragmatism we mean
this is what turns out best for the
majority of people so it must be
it must be right we make a lot of
appeals to to utilitarian kind of
thinking
whether we're utilitarians or not
he's also seeing that there's you know
this this strong
moralizing tendency within
modern thought within modern culture
modern life
not one that was invented of course in
modernity but you know it's it's come
through and even the postmoderns even
the people who are you know
radical and you know gonna make the
world better
or totally pessimistic about the
possibility of the world
very often they're quite moralistic you
can you can find these sort of trends in
them as well
and what is he really concerned with
he's concerned with an appeal to the
crowd
this is where his existentialism is
really coming through
he's concerned with this
putting things up to they're
putting their value up to the
opinions the appreciation of the many
and there's so many things that are
worthwhile
that have
value and the many are a terrible guide
to that
as a matter of fact even the one
unless the one is properly cultivated or
the right things happen to a line may
not see the value in some things
another thing that he's really critical
of is is what he's calling positivism
and oftentimes in this work it's
actually going to be counterposed to
metaphysics
positivism was a movement in philosophy
and in culture more more broadly
that said that we must focus only on
positive questions to which we can give
positive answers we must confine
ourselves to the realm
of the observable of facts we must not
engage in metaphysics
or let alone in theology in mysticism to
use a word that
bertrand russell loved to use and
totally misused because
what he calls what he you know called
mysticism
is very detached from genuine mysticism
which is about mysteries what he meant
was mystification
you know just having sort of vague
sentiments about things
we're going to get rid of all that we're
going to stick to what we what we know
and you can be a positivist not only in
terms of philosophy
but you can be a positivist in terms of
science positivism is really in some
ways kind of a worship of science it
says
you know the methods of science are
going to be the things to solve
everything although usually it doesn't
have a very clear conception of exactly
what science consists in or
if you look at the positivist theories
that have been espoused their notions of
science have been kind of modified over
time
and some of their notions actually
turned out to be kind of kind of crazy
if you look at what quant
actually believed you know coming up
with a whole church of science
but you know reveals what he was really
about
you can have a positivistic sort of
viewpoint
outside of the field of sciences the
science is
and outside of
you know the big questions you can do so
in terms of
commerce you can do so in terms of
consumerism you can do so through
politics you can do so in a lot of
different ways what we ought to be
reading what we shouldn't be reading
in a certain way
positivism isn't empirical enough
it pretends that it's totally empirical
it's getting rid of all this
metaphysical nonsense
but it constrains the realm of
experience far too much
metaphysics means a couple different
things for chest off
and he's using the term in a very
general sense but he's also using in
specific senses
really a strong critic of armchair
metaphysicians who kind of you know
construct imaginary
universes and systems and philosophies
out of their head
and on the basis of very little
experience going far beyond the realm of
of experience and that's something that
kant was critical of that's something
that you know other people have been
been critical of as well
chestoff thinks that
those people are actually
kind of creating fables so the
positivists are in a certain sense right
about that that kind of behavior
he's also criticizing the kind of
metaphysics that say kant was doing
where you're trying to through a
transcendental critique
that is through sort of an examination
on the basis of reason
alone of all the possibilities and
impossibilities of things and what those
in turn require um
that are going to give you you know
yield you universal laws or at least
show you the limits beyond which
you can't really say anything chest off
is extremely critical of that sort of
thing as well
in part because he thinks really when it
comes down to this
they're doing the same sort of thing
they're just claiming to have greater
rigor
they're claiming that you know logic
constrains them to understanding things
this way but really that's not the case
at all
it's quite possible to conceive
the imagination of all sorts of other
possibilities
that you can in fact work out and and
think out in philosophical ways because
guess what people have done it and
saying that
well you know the previous stuff just
doesn't fit into my transcendental
system
that's not really showing that those
other ways of thinking about things
aren't really onto anything that's
showing that they can't fit into your
system
what it is that you're willing what you
want
philosophy to look like and what a lot
of people probably have bought into
and said yeah i want philosophy to look
like that too or it must look like that
i can only accept this sort of thing
because that's what the culture of my
time
is telling me chest off is criticizing
all of these
like i pointed out before as being sort
of you know forms of policing
for ways in which we allow ourselves
to be taken in
and think that we are see there's a
seductiveness to this
we we get to feel like we're in the know
we've got the system out there we have
got the categories
the ironclad laws that must govern
everything
why does it matter to us because we want
to have it we want to
be the ones surveying those things from
on top
there's a problem though as soon as we
do that we wind up below them
and they become the dictators
that tell us exactly what we can and
can't do
and when we establish these sort of you
know ways of barbarian phrase iron cages
of rationality
they're not liberating they may liberate
liberate us from previous systems
previous prejudices
you know historical forms of existence
that we want to leave behind but they
also constrain us
as well so now let's look at some of the
things that he has to say about these
specifically let's begin
with shestop's best criticism as far as
i can see it
of somebody who actually was a great
metaphysician
[ __ ] he says ever since kant succeeded
in convincing the learned
that the world of phenomenon is quite
other than the world of true reality
and that even our own existence is not
our real existence but only the visible
manifestation of a mysterious unknown
substance philosophy has been stuck in a
new rut
and cannot move a single millimeter out
of the track laid by the great kunix
bargain
backwards or forward it can go but
necessarily in the conscient rut
for how can you get out of the
counterposing of the phenomenon against
the thing in itself
and he goes on and he says
um surely the contraposition between the
world of phenomena and the thing in
itself
is an invention of what metaphysics does
the reasoning mind
as is the theory of knowledge deduced
from this contrapposing
wherefore the freedom-loving spirit
could reject it in the very beginning
and there you go
he says we know very well
that if it gets hold of the tip of your
ear he's talking about the devil
but he's also talking about metaphysics
it will carry off your whole body
so it is with reason grant it one single
assumption admit just one proposition
and
finite comedian the the play is over
you were in the toils metaphysics he
says cannot exist
side by side with reason this is very
interesting
because now a dialectical transformation
takes place here he says
metaphysics could not exist side by side
with reason everything metaphysical is
actually
absurd reasonable
is positive
experiential within the realm of what we
know so he says so we come upon a
dilemma the fundamental predicate of
metaphysics is absurdity and yet
surely many positive assertions can lay
legitimate claim to that self seem
highly respectable predicate
there's absurdity on both sides what
then is their means of distinguishing a
metaphysical absurdity from a perfectly
ordinary one
a little bit later he says
all services rendered by reason must be
paid for sooner or later at the
exorbitant price of
self-renunciation
we're all if we want to look at this in
a nichian way we're all sort of
caught up as ascetics if we want to
either be positivists
or we want to be metaphysicians and
if we think that these are the only
alternatives
that itself is a mistaken viewpoint
according to
shasta kant placed us in there
and now we're kind of stuck with it he
says the only way to guard against
positivism
granting of course that positivism no
longer attracts your sympathies
is to cease to fear any absurdities
whether rational or metaphysical
and systematically to reject all the
services
of reason that sounds
quite crazy doesn't it i'm going to just
reject
all the services of reason he says
such behavior has been known in
philosophy and i make bold to recommend
it
credo que absurdum comes from the middle
ages
modern instances are nietzsche and
schopenhauer both present
noble and examples of indifference to
logic and common sense
particularly schopenhauer who a
conscient even in the name of kant made
such daring sally's against reason
driving her into confusion and shame
what is going on here um
he's criticizing kant he's criticizing
in in you know the classical sense he's
criticizing positivism
as a reaction against metaphysics that
really smuggles in its own its own
metaphysics
and all of this is on the basis of
saying that these are choices that
people make
these are not systems that impose
themselves upon us
out of necessity they are ways in which
we
impose necessity upon ourselves or allow
other people to impose necessity upon us
you know it's really if you think about
it
just take kant for one example but you
could come up with innumerable other
ones
why should i feel bound to observe
some limits or even the ways of
conceiving things
that some guy in kingsburg even if he
was a swell
guy and you know had a lot of friends
and wrote some
some cool books why would i
necessarily think that i have to fit
my conceptions into his framework
along the line i've ended up if i'm you
know
the conscience i've ended up accepting
that
this guy had it right probably what i've
accepted is
my teacher has it right and my teacher
really likes kant or
you know the people who are published or
or in the you know
in the know or the intelligentsia have
it right and they accept this guy
and and they think that he's got it
right so i'd better do it myself i'd
better impose it i'd better internalize
it within
my own sphere of freedom and
action and imagination and thought and
i'd better live my life
out as if this this stuff is actually
true now you know
if you were going to say that about some
dogma like
you know stalinist communism we would
all look at that and say
geez that's that's crazy that's the sort
of stuff that you know
um 1984 is made of
but you know when it's a philosopher who
seems much more mild it's just saying
look if
you if you want to get things right
here's how you have to do them
somehow we accept it and if if kant
isn't your your bag for that perhaps
it's hume
or perhaps it's russell or perhaps it's
quine or perhaps it's
nietzsche or perhaps it's you know over
and over again people are buying into
these these positivist frameworks or
metaphysics um
here's some other things that chest off
has to say about doing metaphysics that
are that are quite
interesting actually he says this is
section 23 in the first part the first
assumption of all metaphysics is that by
dialectical development of any concept a
whole
system can be evolved what luck
you can start out with almost nothing
and manufacture a whole system
of course the initial concept the opioid
is generally unsound there's the problem
so there's no need to mention the
deductions but since it's very difficult
in the realm of abstract thought to
distinguish a lie from truth
metaphysical systems often have a very
convincing appearance
the chief defect only appears
incidentally when the taste for
dialectical play becomes blunted
in man so that he realizes the
uselessness of philosophical systems
and this is you know just a brilliant
way to put it
so he says to him who has no taste for
dialectics metaphysics can prove nothing
either
therefore those who are interested in
the success of metaphysics must always
encourage the opinion
that a taste for dialectics is a high
distinction in a man
proving the loftiness of his soul
brilliant thing to say you know
where metaphysics usually begins is with
some sort of
arbitrary ultimately personal choice
on the part of the metaphysician which
doesn't really hold for everybody
and somewhere along the line we forget
that
and and people start saying yeah that
sounds pretty good
and sooner or later it becomes this this
trap of
necessity which is
one of the things
chest off is so keen to
say that doesn't really exist
doesn't really apply the realm of the
necessary is
to to some extent an illusion
even in the lower realm and as applying
to the whole
is completely illusory that's what
shustop wants to wants us to realize
this is actually a good point to make a
detour into his discussions of logic and
necessity
he says this is section 21. the habit of
logical thinking kills imagination
man is convinced the only way to truth
is through logic
and that any departure from this way
leads to error and absurdity
doesn't necessarily need to mean formal
logic the kind of things that we learn
in philosophy classes
something that has structure that has
demanded to have consistency
that's what he means by logic the nearer
he says we approach to ultimate
questions of existence in our departure
from logicality
the more deadly becomes the state of
error we fall into
the ariadne ball has become all unwild
long ago that's the the ball of thread
by which uh theseus was able to find his
way
out of the the labyrinth after he kills
the minotaur because ariadne gives it to
him
and man is at the end of the tether but
he does not know he holds the end of the
thread firmly
and marks time with energy on the same
spot imagining his progress and little
realizing the ridiculous situation into
which he has fallen
how should he realize considering the
innumerable precautions he has taken to
prevent himself from losing
the logical way
he says philosophy must have nothing in
common with logic
this is an extreme stance isn't it
philosophy is an art which breaks which
aims at breaking the logical continuity
of argument and bringing man out onto
shoreless sea of
imagination the fantastic tides where
everything is equally possible and
impossible
and certainly it's difficult given
sedentary habits of life to be a good
philosopher
logic gives us the
the appearance of necessity but we we
again
you impose this upon ourselves
um let me find another
particularly important discussion of
that
a little bit later in section 106 he
says to discard logic as an
instrument as a means or aid for
acquiring knowledge would be extravagant
so
actually it's a bit more tempered he's
saying look in
in the big questions the things that
really
are at the bottom of what concern is to
find our general principles that we're
going to
operate by logic is actually
going to get in our way but you know for
certain things the day-to-day
means are aided for acquiring knowledge
we don't need to get rid of it
why should we for the sake of
consequentialism
that is for logic's very self is logic
really the sort of thing that can say to
us look either you accept me across the
board
or you don't accept me at all well why
would we
accept that on the part of logic why
can't we turn it into what it's supposed
to be
which is merely a tool it's not supposed
to rule over us
it's not supposed to determine
everything from
from the top down of whatever can be or
cannot be
and how everything is connected with
everything else it's merely a tool
aristotle called the organon that was
what logic was originally
or you know the logi k means the
rational or that which is coming through
through speech later philosophers turned
it into
this necessity he says um
against this one must fight even if he
has against himself all the authorities
of thought beginning with aristotle
a little bit later let's talk about the
law of identity
a equals a they say logic does not need
this postulate and could easily develop
it by deduction i think not
i think that we do have to postulate it
he's saying i think that we do
actually if we want logic to work we
have to sort of feed some things into
the machine to begin with
on the contrary in my opinion logic
could not exist without this premise but
where is this
thing a thing is equal to what it is a
thing is what it is where is this
actually coming from
is this something deduced from other
logical
laws axioms no this is coming from
experience
it says it has a purely empirical origin
in the realm of fact a
is always more or less equal to a but
it could be otherwise that which now
equals a
would successively equal b and then c
and so on a stone
at present remains long enough a stone a
plant to plant an animal an animal
but there's nothing unthinkable about
the stone turning into a planet
now science positivism will tell us that
can't possibly be the case
we've observed all these plants and
we've never seen anything like that
we've observed all these stones
we've never seen anything like that
science has
shown that that can't be the case even
though science never actually
shows that that you know something is
absolutely conclusively
deductively the case unless we're
talking about mathematics right
metaphysics on its turns can say that's
not compatible with
our starting points from which we've
spun out this great gigantic system
well so much the worst for them chest
off would say
let's look at a few more passages about
about metaphysics and necessity
and then we will talk about morality and
utilitarianism
he says in
second part section uh
there we go 39 in a long
uh set of passages where he's
criticizing
um what's been going on with with uh
with kant he says
ah priori synthetic judgments
kante as we know found in mathematics
and the natural sciences are priori
synthetic judgments was he right or
wrong
are the judgments he indicated ah prayer
or a posteriori
anyhow one thing is certain they're not
accepted as absolutely but only as
relatively indisputable
and metaphysics where the only curious
and important truths are hidden
the case is different kant was compelled
to admit that just where metaphysics
begins
the capacity of our human reason to
judge a priori ends
but since we can't dispense with
metaphysical judgments he proposed to
substitute for them
postulates
but are our postulates really any any
different
no and he goes on a little bit more he
says
men are greedy they want to learn much
and get their knowledge cheap so they
think that every truth they've paid for
with experience and loss of energy
entitles them to a few more truths
gratis or in philosophical language
a priori by deduction they are not
ashamed to speculate with a gift that's
been given them
instead of looking listening touching
seeking they want to infer and conclude
but nothing comes with their conclusions
say metaphysical systems and empty
prattle
it's surely time just off says
to give up conclusions and get at truth
ah posteriori
through experience as did shakespeare go
dostoevsky
that is every time you want to know
anything go and look and find out
and if one is lazy or horrified at a new
experiment let him train himself to look
on ultimate questions with indifference
as the positivists do it
in a certain way positivism is a
restriction
of our capacities so that we don't
really
experience anything momentous
he also uh goes on and
here we go
um this is in section
one
ah here we are he says um
from a german introduction to philosophy
we shall maintain the opinion that
metaphysics is the crown of the
particular sciences is possible and
desirable
and that to it follows the task
intermediate between theory and practice
experiment and anticipation mind and
feeling the task of weighing
probabilities balancing arguments and
reconciling
differences and so he says this is
chest off oh okay so metaphysics is
weighing
probabilities so further than probable
conclusions it cannot go
but why did metaphysicians then pretend
to universal and obligatory established
in
eternal judgments they go beyond
themselves
in their domain and metaphysics there
cannot must be any established beliefs
it's reasonable to speak of eternal
hesitation and temporarily of thought
there is one other thing i want to hit
on too with respect to positivism
per se he says
in this long section he says
the section 44 experience and science in
the second part
science is useful but she need not
pretend to truth
she cannot know what truth is she can
only accumulate universal laws to that
he might have added and and
notations not experiences notations
about phenomena
whereas there are and always have been
non-scientific ways of searching for the
truth
ways which lead if not to the innermost
secrets yet at least to the threshold
these roads however we've left fallen to
ruin while we followed our modern
methodologies
so we dare not even think of them and
here he says something is really
interesting he's not actually advocating
astrology or anything like that but he
says
what gives us the right to assert that
astrologers alchemists diviners
sorcerers who pass their long nights
alone with their thoughts wasted their
time in vain
why why are we so convinced of that does
anybody actually
know anything about that have they
actually read
you know parseles and seen what he was
actually saying
did he actually have any interesting
thoughts he might have been you know
completely wrong about the nature of
chemistry
but is that all that was going on there
he says
when such surety what does it mean
how do we know that none of these things
matter he says the support of the mob is
a necessary condition of the existence
of modern philosophy
and it's knights of the woeful
countenance scientific philosophy
wearies for a new cervantes who will put
a stop to its paving the ways to truth
by dint of argument all opinions have a
right to exist and if we speak of
privilege
then preference should be given to such
as our most run down today
namely such opinions as cannot be
verified and which are for that cell
same reason
universal a little bit later he says
talking about experience have we humans
got sufficient experience can experience
give us what we want
if so let science
let craftsmanship serve our everyday
need let even philosophy also eager to
serve go on finding universal truths
but is that all there is why why do
people do metaphysics
even if they do it badly and they they
fall into traps
because this realm doesn't have
everything we need he says
beyond craft or we might say technology
in our day
beyond science and philosophy there is
another region of knowledge
through all the ages men each one at his
own risk have sought to penetrate into
this region
shall we men of the 20th century or
shall we
viewers of the 21st century voluntarily
renounce our supreme powers and rights
and because
public opinion demands it
occupy yourselves exclusively with
discovering
useful information or in order
not to appear mean or poverty stricken
in our own eyes shall we accept in place
of the philosopher's stone our modern
metaphysics
which muffles her dread of actuality and
postulates absolutes and such like
apparently transcendental paraphernalia
chestnut sees an oscillation between
these two things and he says
look you're screwed up if you think that
these are the only two options
this isn't satisfying this doesn't give
us what we actually need as human beings
and the only reason why we accept this
is because we're suckers
who let somebody con us into thinking
that this is the only way we can go
over here we're also suckers if we let
somebody
tell us that we can only think things
this way that thought must be
constrained along these lines
that we have to accept this system as
being being the only explanation of
things
we remain within experience we go beyond
experience
and on both sides we we meet up with a
kind of necessity
that really has for its support
ultimately
only the the public opinion
the demand of the crowd now you might
say well what about science science
works and all that he's talking about
something
more than just doing science he's
talking about science
you know sort of a religious worship of
science you know
turning it into the arbiter of all
truths
something that doesn't observe any
proper limits because it thinks that it
can apply to everything
no real scientist actually has that
point of view
only people who don't fully understand
what science is
about think that science addresses all
of our human problems
going beyond experience how do we do it
do we do it just with logic
do we use the imagination do we use our
experience to go beyond
experience and reflect upon it
these are all important things that that
uh
shastaff is trying to bring to light
now i want to talk about utilitarianism
morality why he is criticizing those
i want to make it clear right from the
start that
chest off is not an immoralist in the
sense of somebody who's advocating
sort of a just reversal of morality
and saying whatever people think to be
bad let that be my good
and what they consider to be good is is
simply bad
or anything like that and he's not
saying
um depart from morality
that in most cases we shouldn't actually
pursue the good or that even our in our
normal social life
we don't often have some of the right
intuition some of the right feelings
some of the writers he would say
passions
about them he's not advocating harming
our neighbor
you know simply to
stick it to morality or anything like
that
but he is asking about why do we
take morality in in the full sense
with all that goes along with it as
being sort of an infallible guide for
how we want to act how we ought to run
our lives how we ought to structure our
wills
how we ought to give into or resist our
desires
why do we do that he gives you a couple
different possibilities
he actually says that in some respects
and here he's not just echoing nietzsche
he's echoing a lot of
moralists a lot of people
and he's noting something that we can
see in our own experience
uh day to day depending on
you know how uh good or bad of an
environment we're in
for many people morality rules about
right and wrong notions of good and bad
um making choices praising blaming
judgments all those sorts of things is
an opportunity to exercise
cruelty towards other people it's a form
of aggression
this is actually what gives morality a
bad name this is why nietzsche was
criticizing you know resentment this is
why
um you know the some egoists say
everything is all just self-love at the
bottom
he's not going to say that all morality
is based on that
but that is one of the traps that
morality falls into
another trap is of sort of chaining us
within this
ironclad unbreakable
set of rules that really amounts to
something like a logic
and it ends up being inflexible it ends
up
doing damage to us and to others
it ends up subjecting us
another thing that he talks about is the
fact that a lot of morality really
is kind of based on
self-love selfishness
he's got this great passage this is in
the second part passage 11. it's called
in defense of righteousness he says
inexperienced and ingenious people
see righteousness in righteousness
merely a burden which lofty people have
assumed out of respect for lore for some
other high and inexplicable reason
but a righteous man has not only duties
but rights
true sometimes when the laws against him
he has no he has to compromise
yet how rarely does the law desert him
no cruelty matters in him so long as he
does not infringe the statutes
modesty forbids him to say too much but
if he were to let go what a luxurious
panjirik might he deliver to himself
remembering his works he praises himself
at all times
not allowed but inwardly the nature of
virtue demands it a man must rejoice in
his morality
and ever keep it in mind and after that
people declare it's hard to be righteous
whatever the other virtues may be he
says certainly righteousness has its
selfish side
as a rule it's decidedly worthwhile to
make considerable sacrifices in order
later on to enjoy and calm confidence
all that surety and all those rights
bestowed on a man by morality and public
approval and by talking about public
approval
he's steering us towards what he thinks
morality ultimately
does indeed depend upon
which is something that we we want to to
look at
he's got a lot of interesting
discussions towards the end of section
one where he's talking about
again german philosophers and
metaphysicians he says the germans try
to get at
all germaine guthrie kite being
valid for everybody he says well if the
problem of knowledge is to fathom all
the depths of actual life than
experience in so far as it repeats
itself is uninteresting
um it's necessary however to know what
nobody yet knows and therefore
we must walk not on the common road of
olga mind guti kite but on new tracks
and then he says have you ever been
talking about epistemology seemingly
right
knowledge that he says thus morality
which lays down definite rules and
thereby guards life for a time from any
surprise
exists only by convention and in the end
collapses before the non-moral surging
up of individual human aspirations
he's not saying that that morality is
nothing
he's just saying that the sphere of the
moral crumbles
before what it thought to encompass
and unfold within it but which actually
doesn't
completely remain within there laws all
of them have only a regulating value and
are necessary only to those who want
rest and security
but the first and essential condition of
life is lawlessness
laws are a refreshing sleep and we do
need sleep sometimes
waffleness is a creative activity that's
chester's view
he also ends up seeing
some other useful things
which are going to lead us where we want
to go
he says it's clear to any impartial
observer that practically every man
changes
his opinion 10 times a day much has been
said on this topic
three-fourths of our education goes to
teaching us most carefully to conceal
within ourselves the changeableness of
our moods and judgments
a man who cannot keep his word as the
last of men
never to be trusted likewise a man with
no firm convictions it's impossible to
work together with him
morality here is always
making towards utilitarian ends issues
the eternal principle thou
shalt remain true to thy convictions in
cultured circles this commandment is
considered so unimpeachable that men are
terrified even to appear inconstant in
their own eyes
people become sort of inhabited and
infected by the the moral law
which is supposed to in you know in
certain respects
liberate them and make it possible for
them to live a fully human life but
instead what it does
is it constrains them and he
mentions utilitarianism we looked at
these other
reasons morality leads to
sort of a utilitarian way of looking at
things and what is a utilitarian way of
looking at things
depend on
the many and
what we call public
opinion and the many is
not just an assemblage of people it's
kind of a feeling a mood a pressure
upon the individual conform
see things our way it's interesting
because if you explore
crowds many's okloi you know
uh in greek um multitudes
sometimes you find that they're all
feeling this pressure as well
there's moral pressure to conform and
none of them
actually buy into it none of them
actually like it
they just think that well everybody else
expects me to behave this way
so i'd better you know keep up
appearances and
and go on with this and i'd better make
myself the kind of person who can keep
up appearances so i better impose this
upon myself
then after a while they they forget that
they put on a mask and they think that
that's their actual face
and then when they're there you know
exposed to somebody who doesn't see
things that way they say
you are immoral you're not acting like
the rest of us are and want you to be
doing and they they manage to get that
person
quite often to internalize it as well
um
he says one other thing that that's
quite interesting
uh about this
or in this is vane he says um
where is that 116.
yeah um
the normative theory which has taken
such hold in germany and russia
bears that stamp of the free and easy
self-assurance which characterizes the
state of contentment
and he goes on and he's talking about
this
then he says not every witness will give
evidence so so honestly about about this
it amounts to this philosophical
research
is not a search for truth but a
conspiracy among people who dethrone
truth and
exalt instead the all binding norm
the task is truly ethical morality
always was and always will be
utilitarian and then he says something
else
and bullying it's a way in which the
many
impose upon even if they don't truly in
their hearts of hearts
completely buy into it they impose upon
individuals
a code the need to be self-same the need
to
fit into to the system
and that fits utilitarian ends quite
well i mean it's interesting if you read
john stuart mill
a lot of people want to read on liberty
and they say he's this great libertarian
um read through utilitarianism and pay
very close attention to
sections three and four and you'll see
how
in some respects mill is almost
totalitarian
the proof of utilitarianism will come
when everybody has become a utilitarian
that's the only way you can truly
demonstrate it because it's really based
on a postulate chest off we'd say
there's no reason why you have to buy
into that there's no reason to keep you
from buying into that either for that
matter
he's not saying you have to turn against
morality just
recognize that like logic like science
like metaphysics it sets out these
these systems that are supposed to be
necessities
necessary truths that we all must bow
down to
and restrain ourselves within and that
we're the ones
who choose whether to do that or not
he says a few other interesting things
specifically touching on utilitarianism
and so let's let's actually look at uh
just a few of those and then we'll
finish up
he says
this is in section 43 of the second part
the utilitarian point of view he says
has no place in philosophy
what's the the you know what he's
talking about there he says
you know if a patient fulfills all the
orders of a doctor we say he behaves
wisely
if he neglects his treatment we say
stupid if a healthy person wanted to
inoculate himself
with a dangerous disease we would say he
was mad to such an extent we're
convinced that disease is evil health
good
what is our conviction based upon how do
we know that disease
is actually bad at a glance the question
seems absurd
he says the philosopher has no right to
appeal to the crowd
the many the ordinary person on the
street
the philosopher ought to open up
questions like this
we have to drop the utilitarian point of
view in order to really philosophize
well
common sense tells us sickness is bad
we need to figure that out rather than
just saying whatever the many think
is is the case let's look at another
more uh extensive
passage here we go
this is where he's targeting jon stewart
mill it's better to be an unhappy man
than a happy pig
utilitarians hope by this golden bridge
to get over the chasm which separates
them from the promised land of the ideal
but psychology stepped in and rudely
interrupted
there are no unhappy people the unhappy
ones are all pigs
dostoevsky's philosopher of the
underworld the underground man
rational uh rash colonel
sorry and also hamlet and such like are
not simply unhappy men whose fate might
be esteemed or even preferred before
some
happy fates they are simply unhappy
swines and they themselves are
principally aware of it
this is where he says something really
interesting but first let's dwell on
that and then we'll come back to this
passage
mill was saying yeah better to be
socrates
dissatisfied than a dunce satisfied
better to be you know a human being
dissatisfied than a pig satisfied
because a human being is aware of you
know how
elevated their faculties are and what we
find in
real literature is not this idealizing
it's instead this realization that
we are kind of this entire gamut
i have this this lesser side and even my
pig-like side is not happy
and i'm not
all these great faculties these great
aspirations
i am the whole thing here
mill was kind of hiding that from from
himself
what what shostop ends with here is he
had that
he that hath ears to hear let him hear
this
uh passage that you see in the gospels
over and over again
um the notion is we should actually
see ourselves in that condition that's
what the underground man is actually
inviting us to do in dostoyevsky
um
he tells us in section 78 all our
judgments are permeated through and
through with utilitarianism
and were we to attempt to purify them
from this adulteration what would remain
of modern philosophy
um truths are
what are useful for the many to have
some sort of consistency
modern philosophy is particularly given
to this he thinks
um let's look in section 96
he says
in spite of our high-flow theories we've
always been extremely practical great
utilitarians
this is a constant temptation for us
chest of things there's something about
the nature of human beings that makes us
want to subject our our
thoughts our experiments our
existential position to the many
to common sense if we do that and we
give
in then we will allow morality to put a
complete bind on us and it's probably in
the last estimate going to look
like utilitarianism or it's going to
look like some arbitrary code
or it's going to look like conscientism
but in any case it's going to be a cage
from which we we cannot get out in which
we locked ourselves into
with the help of of other people many of
whom
may feel themselves you know completely
locked in or may not even be aware
that they're part of this this apparatus
like metaphysics logic
like science all of these can become
forms of idolatry and that's what he
thinks has happened in much of modern
philosophy that's what chest off is
criticizing
in philosophy he's not criticizing
philosophy
as such he's criticizing certain
forms which have become very prevalent
in our culture
and he's trying to offer us a way out to
show us a different path
it's not something that he could spell
out entirely because were you to do so
he would be engaging in exactly the same
sort of system building
that he's criticizing so that's a fit
place to leave off i think
and there's still more yet to explore in
this great little
work